ils ont alors mareva galanter vous êtes
amoureuse nous en sommes très heureux
et on va voir tout ce que vous seriez
prête à faire par amour
est-ce que par amour vous seriez prête à
arrêter le cinéma
attention non parce que c'est pas
quelque chose qui me demanderais ah bon
non il est bien et bien ce mec là bien
est-ce que par amour vous seriez prête à
retourner vivre à tahiti aujourd'hui non
mais demain peut-être je veux j'aimerais
être être grand-mère à tahiti reçu grand
mère grand mérite est est ce que par
amour vous seriez prête à cacher
quelqu'un qu'il vient de tuer dix sont
il est carrément habitants
je fais des jeunes mots et à l'homme et
didon chez nous et c'est l'essai trois
mois tu a progressé mais brillant mais
j'ai beaucoup bouquiner non arrête donc
est-ce que par amour ou soyez prêtes à
gâcher quelqu'un qui vient de tuer d'un
coup de couteau dans le ventre blanc qui
la porte
il dit je les buts et chérie et vous
dites et où il est dans le coffre mais
tu dis mais qu'est ce qu'on va faire
il faut que tu m'aides à le cacher fait
quoi la vanille on a calmé dans le
coffre
sinon bon dans le moteur alors là je le
cool je coule le cadavre à vous mettez
les pieds du cadavre dans du béton
vous jetez le cadavre par un pont dans
la seine d'accord d'accord je peux
prendre le même truc que vous ce que
c'est là un très beau
or de rezé est-ce que par amour vous
seriez prête
mareva galanter à vous mettre à la
drogue ben pour eux c'est faire la
charité que je suis le piccolo j'entends
canal+ manière fun et bien scellé
nouveau canapé vivaldi au canada corp la
drogue
imaginez un soir il arrive et vous dit
ça y est moi je me suis accroché à
l'héroïne c'est super essaye montre
tombera feriez quoi je voudrais à ce que
vous dites mais c'est un horrible ça
peut arriver j'ai vu ça déjà
c'est que c'est celle que je bus et
véhicules des questions en l'air ça des
trucs que j'invente est-ce que par amour
vous seriez prête à prendre 17 kg j'en
ai pris dix ans j'étais miss france 2010
est d'accord je vois pas pourquoi oui
bah si l'asnl et rubens ou les botero
peux vous dire a produit sept kilos pour
faire plaisir je crois qu'après tout ça
si le signe du vent et tout ça je serais
plus je serai pas longtemps je voudrais
pas dire une seule question peut-il de
kuro d'irma la douce
est-ce que par amour vous seriez prête à
embrasser cent fois ses chaussettes sage
arriva à voulez mais un peu quand même
est-ce que par amour vous seriez prêt à
vous faire refaire le nez
pourquoi il est pas bon moment si si
mais c'est pas la question
oui mais justement lui vous et lui il
aime ça à des groupes dissous alors
quand même pas imaginé que je pourrais
devenir après tout ça si je vous ai tous
à bout 7 kg le groupe ben oui parce que
pour la drogue et tu sais
bon non mais c'est un test c'est pour
voir s'ils s'aiment
est-ce que par amour ou seriez prête à
accepter quelques petite toute petite
infidélité au bon moment et au bon mot
juste le bout alors si on est complice
pourquoi pas à un des récents je trouve
ça dégueulasse
est-ce que par amour vous accepteriez
qu'il est une maîtresse non je voulais
même pas des questions si ça le rend
heureux d'avoir une maîtresse il peut
pas être heureux d'avoir une maîtresse
avec moi c'est pas possible donc vous
vivez pas à trois avec la maîtresse
non vous refuseriez d'aller tous les
droits dans des clubs échangistes c'est
pas la peine que je me pose ces
questions
moi je me crève le culot à faire les
questions et je vous écris répondre
voilà alors tant pis est-ce que par
amour vous seriez prête à devenir son
esclave sexuelle
et ben voilà galanter
3-0 le vide
vienne tv la mission